Ringgold: When I was little,
There were no cars on the street.
Few had cars.
She was born in 1930 in Harlem
On street number 146,
My work has now reached all over the world.
In Guggenheim, Tate, and everywhere else.
[singing]
I am curious that I did not think I was
I will become an artist.
I think the artist
He does something ordinary.
They are all artists.
Look at this, it's beautiful.
The art that people make comes from
From their vision of colors,
I saw many formations of beautiful colors
I convey what I see to my work.
Everyone can fly. Just try, and you will.
The most important thing in life for me
Is inspiration.
I want to inspire others,
And get inspiration.
Do not you see this great thing?
[Sound drum music]